in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us flat duty of our streaming
service CBS n is back to introduce us to
a New York City man who's using his love
of archery to improve his community blag
good morning
Jericka good morning to you we visited a
basement cafeteria at a Brooklyn middle
school right here in New York City but
this story isn't about chicken nuggets
and Taco Tuesdays it's about bows and
arrows and one man's desire to help
students aim for greatness this was your
first that was your second as your third
yeah not bad at all
Larry Brown has dedicated his life to
archery can you describe the feeling you
had when you first pulled back oh my
father was one day he took myself and my
two brothers out to a garbage dump in
Queens got a cushion and taught us how
to shoot and that's how it started and
I've been doing it ever since you didn't
have a coach no he wasn't just missing a
coach his bow was carved from a
neighborhood treat baseball football
basketball I'm in the backyard and the
next thing I knew I had I had other kids
wanting to learn how to shoot growing up
in a tough Queens neighborhood Brown's
skill launched him into the Ivy League
as head coach of the women's archery
team at New York's Columbia University
Combee I had 14 students for four years
varsity n-c-double-a division one the
whole nine yards but when I was the
tournament's I see any black around
children said you know what I'm in my
50s now can you make it a little change
here you have that please the boot case
it was a big change
Brown stepped away from Columbia and
went back to his roots in the public
school system teaching archery basics to
hundreds of New York City children put
your bow on him it wasn't about a job it
was about a mission and that's what made
it much more comfortable for me to do
and I've been doing that for now going
on 16 years Brooklyn native Dallas Jones
is one of Brown's prized pupils he
dropped it down just enough
that went dead center so you first came
here when you were 10 years old yeah
Matt you're 16 and you're nationally
ranked yes and now you're getting ready
to compete for a spot on the United
States on the vacant archery team yes
sir I can tell it's gonna be a fun
experience I'm not gonna try to put too
much stress on myself
Archie's about having fun if I don't
have fun it's no point of doing Dallas
Jones Jones is the first African
American in history to win a u.s.
national archery tournament and has his
eyes fixed on competing in the 2020
Olympics in Tokyo you see yourself not
only as a pioneer but also as a role
model I certainly hope so I can be a
role model to anybody else that didn't
know too much about this sport I surely
hope I can get more people into the
sport and especially people of color and
not just to section it off and won't get
everybody to this board when you see how
successful Dallas has been what goes
through your mind the same joy and
happiness answer your question straight
up but the success that I see with him I
also see in children who don't get as
far as he did but they came through the
program and he learned from it one of my
students started this program here in
Brooklyn at 11
she just got her master's degree so they
both rose to the top different fields
but they came through the same Channel
Brown's teachings impact students well
beyond just the bow and arrow imparting
wisdom they can carry with them even off
the range okay got you the greatest
award is them I mean outside of the
metal outside of getting paid outside of
all the external attributes the true
growth is the reward of a living person
doing what you taught them to do and it
changes their life Dallas is already
looking beyond the upcoming Olympic
setting his goals to make the Olympic
team three times at least
that's what I love about sports I mean
no matter what type of sport it is that
discipline that people learn and learn
at such an early age and you can't say
no enough times a great teacher is such
an important the school is Center shot
archers he teaches in a basement of a
cafeteria school cafeteria but the kids
all flock to this we went there we
checked it out you know little brown and
black kids and that's just not common in
archery it just isn't in this country as
we talked about all the time you just
need to see one person who looks like
you doing something you wouldn't
expected to open up that door I love
that he started Larry Brown started in a
girl but you don't been cool tree limb I
did I was terrible oh my god my arrows
went all over the place if we're running
thanks black